- Court is in session.
(inspirational music)
- Plaintiff Mr. Cohen is
suing his current roommate
Mr. Huber for only showering once a week,
and using a self-prepared
slurry of avocado, oatmeal,
and egg whites in place
of commercial shampoo.
- Alright gentleman, why are
you here before me today?
- My roommate Mr. Huber is on
like this vegan all-natural
kick and as such he has
foregone all basic hygiene,
like shampoo, soap, toothpaste,
(sighs)
he mells like garbage.
- I mean you're not supposed
to shower, you know,
every day of the week,
so I have developed my own
concoction that is all-natural,
with no chemicals.
- And your objection with it is what?
It smells bad, it's making you sick?
- He smells like the
last day of Burning Man.
- Sir you come before the
court, but what damages
are you looking for here?
- I'm looking for 650 dollars
in reimbursements for groceries.
(pounding)
(laughs)
(gavel banging)
- No more outbursts.
- Everyday.
- How did you arrive at that figure?
- Yeah, good.
- I mostly just multiplied
by two or three the amount
of groceries that I bought.
- So that's, the amount
of avocados, pro rata?
- Amortize the arbitration--
- Amortize the arbitration,
the pro rata over the course of the--
- Depreciation.
- The FICA, sure, yeah, that makes sense.
- How am I supposed to know,
if we both buy avocados,
how am I supposed to know
that I'm using his avocados?
I mean they're all in one basket.
- Yeah I have a couple
questions about the avocados.
Hard, or soft?
- Soft, I get them whenever
the ripe sticker is on them.
- Thick, or long?
- Thick.
- Girth?
- We're talking--
- Girthy, very girthy.
- Very girthy--
- Yeah, little seed, very girthy.
- Understood, tell me again
what the other elements
of this were, the avocados and--
- So it's half an avocado.
- Half.
- A tablespoon of coconut
oil which I melt down.
I process some oatmeal, put that in there
and then I also use one egg.
And he only eats egg whites so I
(gavel banging)
- If it pleases the court, and it does,
I would like the defendant to
please step forward and see
me in chambers.
(suspenseful music)
(inhales loudly)
- That's disgusting, it's
gonna make the, you can return.
- That's what I deal with every day.
- Understood.
- Every day.
He smell's like leftover Denny's.
- I have brought Exhibit A.
- I got all the exhibit
I'm willing to get, sir.
If you stank, you are not dank.
That's what they say.
I watched the People vs. OJ Simpson.
- Me too.
- It's amazing isn't it, dude!
- Right, it's good.
- Isn't it amazing?
- I'm kind of addicted to it.
- Oh my God, how crazy is John Travolta?
He's like doing a thing.
- His face kind of doesn't
move, it's just like
- [Judge] Oh it's amazing.
- [Mr. Huber] Yeah, it's really good.
- How long has this conflict been brewing?
- I've been doing this vegan
all-natural organic shampoo
for six months.
- If it bothers Mr. Cohen
so much, why can't you
just use shampoo?
- I used a shampoo face
wash body wash one time,
and it made me break out
into hives, so I haven't
trusted it since.
- I'm just trying to get a
picture of what the conflict is
really like, beyond the terrible smell.
So just that, if we can
solve that then we can bring
prosperity and happiness.
- I never knew that he
felt this way about me.
- I tell him every day.
- Mmhmm, mmhmm, mmhmm.
- Anything further that you
would like the court to know
before I render a decision?
- That I don't use my product on animals,
(laughs)
so I mean, I'm doing
good stuff here with--
- Do you have animals?
- At home?
- Like in his hair?
- I mean where?
- Sure I mean there's animals everywhere.
- But do you have animals anywhere?
- No.
- Well then, isn't it disingenuous sir,
to come before this court and claim
that you do not test on animals?
That you just admitted,
you don't have anywhere.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
You know, the court is reminded
of Joseph Stalin, who said
- Of course
- "You can't make an omelet
without breaking some eggs."
- Exactly.
- Perchance you--
- Can't have good hair
- can't make a fragrant
scent without breaking
somebody else's eggs.
- No you definitely can,
you can use shampoo.
(gavel banging)
- I've heard enough the court
will now render a verdict,
after a moment of deliberation.
(suspenseful music)
The court
(gavel banging)
hereby finds the favor of that guy.
(claps)
- Woo!
- Thank you that's today's business.
Everyone dismissed, thank you.
(gavel banging)
(dramatic music)